practiquemos sumar y restar números
negativos voy a poner un ejemplo voy a
poner aquí el 2 menos 3 entonces estoy
restando los números positivos pero
puedes ver que estoy restando un número
mayor que otro cierto el 13 es mayor que
el 2 y está del lado derecho entonces
esto pero probable no de hecho no
probablemente sino que va a terminar
siendo un número negativo el resultado y
podemos pensar en esto por momento voy a
dibujar aquí una recta numérica ponemos
aquí el 0 1 y 2 y el menos 1 y el menos
2 y podemos empezar desde el 2 entonces
iniciamos desde aquí y vamos a restar 3
de ese 2 entonces nos movemos 3 pasos
hacia la izquierda 1 2 y 3 y ahí lo
tenemos entonces esto es igual a menos 1
y ahora vamos a mezclar un poco las
cosas vamos a imaginemos que ahora vamos
a restar menos 2 menos tres entonces
primero teníamos un 2 positivo menos 3 y
ahora tenemos un 2 negativo
y lo que voy a hacer es otra vez dibujar
la recta numérica entonces aquí voy a
poner al 0 al 1 y acá tengo al menos 1 -
2 - 3 - 4 menos 5 menos 6 y así yo
podría seguir indefinidamente entonces
iniciamos en el menos dos y nos movemos
tres hacia la izquierda así que vamos a
movernos sería 1 2 y 3 y terminamos en
el menos 5
esto es igual entonces a menos 5 y nota
que en ambas situaciones restamos 3 pero
aquí inicié yo con un 2 a la derecha del
0 mientras que acá inicio con un 2 a la
izquierda del 0 hagamos otro ejemplo
para que quede esto un poco más claro
voy a poner aquí que te parece el menos
2 menos 2 + 3 menos dos más 3
anímate a poner pausa el vídeo y
inténtalo tú mismo pero bueno sigamos
pongo aquí la recta numérica aquí van
aquí yo pongo el menos 2 el menos 10 1 y
2 iniciamos con el menos 2
y el 2 a la izquierda del 0 y sumamos 3
entonces avanzas 3 hacia la derecha 1 2
y 3 y nos queda 1 positivo así que la
respuesta aquí es 1 positivo ahora voy a
hacer otro ejemplo
otro ejemplo digamos que yo tengo tengo
2 positivo y le restamos un 3 negativo
entonces hay un vídeo donde yo explico
por qué esto tiene sentido jaja pero
cuando tú estás un número negativo lo
que estás haciendo esto es lo mismo que
sumar el positivo
deja explico esto de otra manera digamos
que esto lo mismo que 2 + 3
es lo mismo que dos más 3 estos dos
argumentos son equivalentes y tenemos
que esto es igual a 5 ahora hagamos otro
ejemplo vamos a mezclar un poco más las
cosas digamos que yo tengo el que te
parece si hace
2 negativo entonces menos 2 y le
restamos menos 3 y puede ser que ver
todos estos signos negativos te intimide
un poco pero simplemente debes recordar
tu recuerda que cuando tú restas un
número negativo te da un número positivo
en este caso esto es lo mismo es
exactamente lo mismo que menos 2 + 3 lo
cual ya habíamos resuelto antes aquí
está arriba mira iniciábamos en el menos
2 que está a la izquierda del 0 y
avanzábamos 3 pasos hacia la derecha
entonces 1 2 y 3 nos queda uno positivo